moms turned babies into boys
but it's the dads who turned boys into
men and when the dads are absent or
emotionally absent in other words there
but emotionally disconnected and when
they haven't been taught how to be a man
how to stand up and Shake hand you don't
just say hi to someone you you stand up
shake hands make eye contact if a
woman's going up the escalator you stand
behind her if she's going down the
escalator you stand in front of her
you're walking on a sidewalk with a
woman a man walks on the street side
you're opening doors for women you're a
Savage and a servant you're a lamb and a
lion are you going to show up as a
passive aggressive man or are you going
to show up as a guy who can protect
provide and preside meet his family